hi
i've been looking at uh
several films on youtube lately
and uh
it's taken my mind away from the
technical side
and
if you look up
the sensor yourself i'm going to talk a
little bit about
energy and
you may be interested in just
hearing about it or you may find it of
no interest whatsoever
i've said before that the majority of
aikidoka aren't really interested in
i haven't found any in the working of
the energy side
i'll explain that a bit more because
energy is just a short word isn't it
but the person i've recently
uh seen a youtube film of is um
sheehan um robert nadeau
he
doesn't mind me called bob either
sorry
rob bob
he's confusing me now because uh the way
he uses it okay so
so let's say uh
scentsy nado
he's been doing
energy work and talking to his students
and those
have been to interview him and see him
for a long time
i'd just like to give you a little bit
of background
about this
i used to go in the early 80s i first
met cytosensei in person
in new zealand in 1983.
he was very technical
and always has been but
such smoothness and timing
he must have been working on on another
level
that i've found out over the years you
have to be on
but um
nado essentially he's
been on about
this energy and what he got for most
scentsy
i don't know how long he stayed in iwama
but uh
he was with those scentsy in i said his
later years
when her sensei really was um
talking in languages that nobody really
understood him his students didn't
anyhow
and um
he was intrigued
since in the nada was
intrigued in those senses um
i said methodology the way he would
uh demonstrate his aikido
so he was at a time where that was more
important
to him
than just the technical side or that's
how i read it
i went to after
meeting such a sense in new zealand in i
think it was february 83
i was recommended by new zealand chap to
go to california
where
it was classed as cytosexy's best top
world student um
bruce clickstein
now we've found that in later on bruce
glickstein
sadly
was not a good person in himself
but if we could just separate that for a
moment
and look at the technical aikido
when i used to attend
so i would go and i'd butcher living in
the dojo
and i found him apart from saito sensei
the absolute best i'd ever
seen
and his power was
ridiculously enormous
he could throw me as if i'm throwing
a cardboard beer mat on these
little
fiber mats they put on the bar to put
your beer
i never experienced anybody who could
throw me with such ease and so fast
because i'm a big guy and i always have
been and i've not been a good uk
as far as lightness
concerned but uh carrying on from that
i
going there several years
i then timed it so that i could go while
in the dojo to a gathering that was like
a summer retreat
where you would get lots of different
teachers
teaching
at the time
senses like
juan luins pat hendrix
kim persa
bernice tom
billwitt
all these senses
um were
not that old nor was i
and that i met them as friends really
but as also practitioners on the met and
i and
i think younger still
or maybe the same age as senator
hendrickson kayla fader
was another person that really impressed
me
she had superbly clear aikido
so
i would go to summer school and
we would have different senses come and
the current doshu when he was 37
he came one year
we trained on his mat
at this summer camp
and um
i'll call him uh bob dodeau because
that's as i knew of him then
he came on
and um
really wide posture stances
and i felt as if he had a lot of
charisma
he did attract a lot of young ladies and
i don't know whether
that was
talking about the energy work or his
smooth style
but
not many
men i found at the time
followed him
not in vast numbers
so
i used to watch him and then
after class when we'd all finished in
the evening so
i thought one day i'll ask if i could
talk to him about
what he
saw as this energy work that he talks
about
and i asked it after a particular
session when
he called up her sensei hendrix
as i say she was a very young lady then
i can't remember what age but
you
know you work it back in the time
it was in the early 80s let's say it was
i guess say 1985
and now i'm 72 in 2022.
so work it out
anyhow he called cindy hendricks out it
was okay he told her to turn the other
way
and said
when i say attack i want you to attack
me on a yokomanuchi
sensei hendrick's done this turn the
other way and he made like a circle with
his arm over his head just as your co
scentsy doing it with a joe
so he made like a spy but he was making
like a spiral circle and i
thought what was he doing
he then said
or whatever the instruction was to
say hendricks
she turned
at high speed attacked him in the
yokomanuchi
she didn't even touch his head but the
next thing she was flying
at
you know his his head a height
and she took ukemi
at such a height
it was unbelievable to see anybody could
just from a yockerman attack go into a
flight
it was if she was flying
in the creation of what he made earlier
the spiraling
circle that he made earlier
i
like most other people
was quite amazed at what he'd achieved
by
knowing
pat as
a friend and student at the time
i looked at her as she was getting off
the mat
and her face was completely white as if
everything had been drained out of her
i've never told her about this but
and i wondered what he could have done
to create this type of uh void sphere
whatever you may wish to call it
so i thought i'm going to ask him i'm
going to find out what what this is all
about because you can't see nothing but
there must be something there
so
i asked him and he said let's have
coffee and doughnuts that's what his
exact words
so that evening
we met up i didn't have coffee and
doughnuts i don't think but i know he
did
and as i sat on his left side
he was talking to him about energy
but he was talking more as if
he was drifting off his mind was
drifting back
as if he wasn't really there you know he
was he was getting video film i think
come into his mind
now
watching him from the mid-80s
to recently in 2022
he still seems to be
white coal and i don't mean this rudely
sense if you ever see it
but he comes across a little bit of a
scatter brain
because he goes
and then he starts speaking
it may just be a characteristic of the
human being rather than the
the martial artist
i didn't follow him because i felt as if
if you can't understand somebody why
would you follow them
he doesn't talk in riddles like i sense
he was supposed to be but he does
and i
i'm asking you to sort of look up some
of his work and see if you can
understand it
i certainly can't or let me put it this
way i certainly couldn't
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make some a series of a few films
talking about how i see
energy
he calls it an outer circle the center
the center to the outer circle and he
talks about a circle and he talks about
the center
but to me a layman
who needs things spelling
pretty much
in plain english
i've never understood him
a lot of people say oh it's really deep
it's really you know
but what i think it is
it takes a lot to be centered
in any martial art i think it takes
years of study
so by just saying
it beyond the center
there's the circle your energy goes out
to the circle and and
i implore you to
to study him
watch some of his films
and
come back to me with any information
that you
think prevalent that i'm missing
so
his aikido works that i've seen with my
own eyes
he's got
good techniques as well as far as the
technical aikido goes he's as she had
he's been around many many years devoted
his life pretty much now to
aikido
so
i
admire him as one of our greats
and
he has given me some keys
to open
doors of my own
and that's what i'll be talking about in
this series of energy work
if you're just interested in pure
technical
uh save your time and don't even
uh listen to these until you're ready to
listen
so
have a look at his films when you can
look what you can find it's robert
nudeau
and he's from the bay area in california
and see what you make of
his lectures
and anything that you can find
and then come back to me with questions
please and i'll if i don't answer them
you may even be able to tell me what
what i'm missing
but but put together technical and what
he's found for my scentsy
and i believe
um that's what we all should be looking
for
the problem is
we've got to understand it
clearly
and we've got to be at a stage
where it's a benefit to us
i think you'll agree or i hope you agree
thank you for your time